there's so much to talk about with when
it comes to the finale so if you don't
mind i'll just kind of dive in
and ask you about killing tracy and
gordon
yeah that was a big deal um we spent a
lot of time
uh puzzling that through in the writers
room you know we
had come up with this we would set all
the pieces in place
and were trying to decide how they were
going to play themselves out and there
were certainly
various characters were in jeopardy in
various different ways
and as we started talking about the
possibility of having
one or both either gordo or tracy take
that last run then you start talking
about whether
they should die and would one of them
die would both of them die
and we went round and round on it for a
while internally
and ultimately i think what carried the
day was just
our sense that this was the right ending
to their story as
characters that it felt like we had
taken them on a journey
uh from season one and shown you how
they
first met then the tre you know then the
troubles in their marriage
then tracy gets this opportunity how
that affects gordo's life then they
split between the seasons
and the two of them coming back together
on the moon
and finding each other finally at the
very end and then
dying together in this heroic endeavor
seemed like
the right way to end their story and
even though we were
sort of all heartbroken about it because
we love the characters and we love the
cast members you know
we love sarah sarah and michael and it
was hard but um
at the end we just sort of felt like it
was the right thing to do and it felt
like
that's that's the satisfying ending to
the story of tracy and gordo
now was this a situation where you knew
that the you knew that the actors
wouldn't be
available for season three and then so
it was kind of a way of
writing writing towards that or did you
decide
the opposite way it was the opposite i
mean they were available we
we could have continued both characters
and we had plans you know we had
preliminary plans you know
because we had sort of sketched ahead
multiple seasons in the show and
we started ideas about what we were
going to do with them in the third
season
but um the story just sort of took us
there so it really wasn't about
actor availability at all it must be
nice to have that kind of freedom within
the writers room
it is it's great you know i mean it's
it's a very open very free room and i i
always try to tell my writing staffs
come up with the idea that's crazy come
up with something that's shocking you
know say this say the thing that you
don't think you can say and let's
you know most of the time you're not
going to do it you know a lot of the
times you're just going to ask
that's too much but sometimes it is the
right move and sometimes when somebody
says it
everybody came and takes a step back and
goes oh i don't know if we can do that
and then you start talking it through
and you start seeing the opportunities
and the possibilities
and then you shy away from it and then
you just keep finding yourself like
like a gravitational force coming back
to it so we literally it was pitched out
early
and then you know gordon tracy could die
when they go on that run
and we all went ah no let's not do that
but it just kept coming back up it just
it would not the idea wouldn't die in
the writer's room and we just kept
coming back to it until it was clear
that
it was just the right place to go gotcha
so in terms of leaping forward to 1994
for season three you know we saw in the
leap from season one to season two that
you know you we get we get some of the
details about what happened between in
those years
that gets skipped over but not a lot and
they kind of trickle in
is that is that similar to the approach
we're taking for season three
yeah it'll be a very similar approach we
want to you know
let the audience be surprised by the
changes of what's happened where the
characters are in their lives
what's happened in the world and then
give them a certain sort of framework of
okay here's some historical events and
some cultural events that happened in
between the two seasons
but then as the season goes on you keep
making references to things that
happened in the intervening years
there's things that are on television
there's things in newspapers there's
like casual lines that are thrown out
little easter eggs along the way
you know apple has also had this uh as
part of the platform
you know we had certain bonus uh pieces
that that we put in there that also
filled in there were news broadcasts
there were sort of confessionals there
were
you know other historical pieces that we
put on the platform for people that were
really really interested
in those alternate history ideas you
know what else because we
worked out a lot of that stuff so here
it is if you're interested
here's another way to go experience that
yeah i mean
it's actually funny uh i i remembered
recently the very first set visit for
the show that i ever got to do
uh before it had ever come out and i
asked you
uh about you know what's the divergent
point what what is the one thing that
happened that led to
the russians beating the americans to
the moon and you
you said what it was there and i'm not
mentioning it now just because a it
might have changed in the years
but be you i don't think we've we've had
that been revealed on the show
and i was curious like is that something
you ever do plan to reveal
oh uh i know what you're talking about
and actually yeah it's just
uh it's it it's not a huge player i'll
just give it to you know the our point
of divergence was the idea that sergey
korlov who was the father of the soviet
space program
uh in reality he died during
an operation in moscow in the mid 60s
and
after that point like their moon program
really never
pulled together like they developed the
in one rocket but it kept blowing up and
it just it kind of
it all kind of fell apart in the race to
the moon and our point of divergence was
that
corelog lives and that somehow he was
able to pull all the bureaucratic pieces
together and the technological
challenges
and he kind of made their moon landing
happen that was the point of divergence
for us
we had always sort of tried to figure
out a way to mention it
but it never quite there was never like
an organic
easy way to sort of casually say that
somebody did not die in an operation
you know so we never quite figured out a
way to really
cement that into the story and um
i think we had we we might have
mentioned the name corelog in dialogue
somewhere or maybe
that got dropped out but it's kind of
one of those things i think we've
sort of forgotten because it's so far
now in the past of of our creative
process that we haven't ever actually
kind of pinpointed it on camera that
that's the point of divergence
in terms of season three what else do
you feel comfortable teasing at this
point
well you know just that not much just
that it's it jumps does jump to the 90s
and mars is clearly you know a big focus
of
what season three is about and uh the
rest of it you know we're just kind of
keeping under wraps for now
the season two flash forward that
happens at the end of season one
we do see that scene in the context of
season two but it's you know
it's not the kickoff point for season
two it's kind of deep into the middle of
the season
is that similar to how is that is the
mars landing that we see
at in the teas for at the end of season
two a similar approach
uh i'd rather not say that's right one
thing i do want to make sure i ask about
uh getting nirvana uh for the final
moments was that
as hard as you might have expected or to
come together pretty easily
i can't you know it's just a question of
money ain't cheap
i'll put it that way but none of the big
songs are cheap so
we've you know we've used everyone from
sinatra to nirvana to the rolling stones
and ac dc at this point so
we we kind of know what we're in for and
we budget accordingly
well that's my time with you thank you
so much and uh
can't wait for season three good luck
with it great thank you very much